with hindsight uh do you think
that this shouldn't have been pursued
that the the suspension should have just
been left
to continue
well i think it's important uh to
remember that the prime minister and in
your opening remarks you talked about
today's summit and youth and
uh of course um uh climate is incredibly
important and it's youth and education
day here in glasgow but the prime
minister's always been very clear that
you know paid lobbying is not allowed uh
the uh i think the mistake uh which to
your point your question is uh the
conflation of creating a fairer system
with the right of appeal uh for
parliamentarians um to be able to put
forward
effectively you know an appeal process
and then conflating that with a
particular case of owen patterson was a
mistake and i think the leader of the
house jacob rees-mogg came to the house
yesterday upon reflection yes it was a
mistake and i think it was right to come
back very quickly
to the house and say look we need to
separate those two things out we should
work on a cross-party basis to create a
fairer system i think that's a good
thing and my appeal to my fellow
parliamentarians from all parties is
look let's come together and create a
better system with the right of appeal
and it was right to separate the two
things out that was the mistake and i
think it was right to reflect and return
to parliament and correct that
do you accept then that owen patterson
did something wrong
well i think look the uh commissioner
had investigated and had come back uh on
uh the
investigation around what owen patterson
was doing in terms of
uh his work for two companies uh that is
as i said to you the prime minister has
always been clear that that paid
lobbying is wrong um and we need to
separate those two things out as i say
the thing to focus on is not this
particular case but to focus on creating
a fairer system with the right of appeal
for all parliamentarians
but are you voted for this for this
change didn't you i mean i mean
obviously there was there was the the
whip involved in this but we know an
awful lot of your your uh colleagues on
the back benches were really really
uncomfortable with this
why did you feel the need to vote for it
well again i would uh say to your
viewers that i take collective
responsibility i'm a secretary of state
uh a cabinet member in this government
and we voted uh because i thought
actually improving the system and
introducing a right of appeal as you
would have in many sectors of the
economy in many professions people have
a right of appeal i think your viewers
would understand there's a fairness
argument here but upon reflection i do
think it's a mistake to have conflated
that with a specific
issue around the investigation into owen
patterson and i think it was right that
we reflected on that and the leader of
the house came back to the house
yesterday and
basically said
as much that it was a mistake and we
need to separate those three things out
and i hope we'll be able to return with
proposals and have a cross-party
agreement as to how we improve the
system to introduce a right of appeal
into it
i mean
was how much of this
change of heart and and this you 19-hour
later u-turn from number 10 on this you
say it was because you didn't want to
conflate the issues but how much of that
was driven by the fact that
mr patterson told our deputy political
editor he'd do it again
well i don't want to comment on uh
anything that um you know
owen pastor said on the interviews
other than to say the prime minister
made a very clear statement um
recognizing owen patterson's 24 years of
service recognizing uh that let's not
forget you know there is a family here
that have just lost a mother and a wife
um who he and his family were devoted to
and there's a bit you need a bit of
compassion our hearts as well
but in saying that the mistake that i
think we want to correct
is to separate that out and this
particular case from what i think is the
right thing to do and the fair thing and
the for parliament to concentrate on is
to get our appeals process in place for
all parliamentarians in the future
well i mean mr patterson wants some
compassion doesn't he when he's resigned
he said he stepped down to escape the
cruel world of politics i mean a cruel
world that along with his lobbying it
was netting him about 200 or very nearly
200 grand a year i don't think the
public's gonna
be overly sympathetic are they and you
need to bear that in mind
well i think the the the public will
make their own judgment uh on this um
all i would say
is that um
it's worth remembering that there is a
family here concerned who've just lost
um a mother um there are children and of
course owen himself
but the public will make up their own
mind on this i think the priority has to
be now for us and i hope i can appeal to
my colleagues across the house let's
shed our political differences aside
let's not play politics with this let's
get the system right because the system
does need a right of appeal and that's
the fairest thing to do and that's what
i think andrea ledson was trying to
achieve with her amendment
now that didn't work i think it was
right for us to come back to parliament
and for the leader of the house say look
we think we made a mistake by conflating
the two things
in one and i think now is the time to
come together and just deal with the the
process
uh to which we you know we hold
ourselves to account
forgive me though i mean this has been
an absolute shambles in terms of
management hasn't it from from number 10
down i mean even with i mean one of your
colleagues matt shawley saying on
twitter even if voters forget this
shambles tory mps won't scores of them
held their nose had arms twisted faced
abuse online and in post bags and now
boris johnson has made them look like
idiots they'll remember that the next
time there's a rebellion
well as i say look the important thing
is for all parliamentarians on all sides
now to focus on what is truly material
what is material is and i've spoken to
the speaker of the house and i think he
agrees with me on this what's material
is to maintain confidence in the
processes and the system that we have in
place and improve it if we can through a
right of appeal that's something that's
worth working on that's something that's
worth putting energy into
rather than you know putting
i'd rather focus on that than waste my
my energy and time on on on sort of your
tit-for-tat or being angry
okay well what about apologizing then to
to someone like catherine stone um
because i mean there are questions as to
whether the conservative party has made
her position untenable through no fault
of her own actually but quasi kwa tang
said yesterday she should just she she
now needs to decide her position
i mean for what for doing her job
well first of all i think it's important
to um you know remind
all uh
parliamentarians and of course your
viewers the country at large that
catherine stone
the commissioner works for the house
for parliament for the legislature and i
think it's only right that i echo uh you
know the words of the speaker by saying
actually uh it is up to the house um how
uh uh
the the the commissioner and the
procedures actually are delivered and i
think that's the important thing to
remember and this that's what i would i
would leave it i was hoping we were also
going to talk about youth and education
uh day to day at cop 26 but you know
happy to continue talking about the
procedures of parliament if that's what
you know well yeah we will talk about
the youth in just a second but but one
final point on this then
there is an acceptance is there from
what you say that quasi quartet did
actually speak out of turn yesterday
as i say it's important that uh to
remember and i don't think quasi was
saying anything different that actually
katherine said the commissioner
has a responsibility to the legislature
to the house of commons and the speaker
was absolutely right in reminding all of
us uh that that is uh the correct thing
to do um uh and look
i'm happy uh to continue uh talking
about this but i hope we can also talk
about what i'm launching today which is
our sustainability and climate change
strategy which will i hope support
teachers to deliver
you know evidence-led
education through stem science subjects
through geography and of course
through citizenship
to our students including the primary
model science curriculum
primary school as well and of course
we're launching a a national education
park if you take all our schools
nurseries colleges and and universities
they're about you know
the size of two birmingham cities
of parkland and land that we think we
can create a sort of a virtual coming
together of all of that uh parkland to
to teach young people about biodiversity
about spatial planning about uh
geospatial mapping all these things are
incredibly exciting and it's worth just
you know i hope leaning into youth and
and
climate day to day